I know that there are people who would be happy even if I take revenge.I know that it is
beyond my power and that no one wants
revenge, but
still, there is nothing I can do about this pain and
hatred.
Well, it's probably
best to do a bunch of incomprehensible things before you take revenge, but you don't want to take
revenge for anyone or anything, you just do it because you
hate it.
Revenge is
fun after you've cleared it up.  Don't do it, encourage me.What should I do?The
witch has just given a notice.Three days later, when she
comes to my book, it seems like there's
someone she wants to kill no matter what.Is it okay to believe that?Is it
okay to really believe that you guys will make it come true for the witch?It's obvious, right?  I'll give
you the real pleasure of revenge
[music]